Alright,
so before we begin,
I want to say to the video that you're
about to watch is one of our additional
commentary videos,
uh,
they're very low key on the editing
side,
so don't expect anything too fancy.
And they were basically just meant to
add some things or respond to comments
about the original video essay in the
past.
We made these for our patrons only,
but from now on,
these additional commentary that will be
posted on our second channel,
which is called the storytellers
podcasts.
The link for that is in the description.
This is because we're working on a
complete patron and channel makeover,
which we're really excited about.
We're working together with a graphic
designer to help us build a or make a
better banner,
more professional,
better,
and it's looking really good.
So I,
I hope it will be up in a couple of
weeks probably.
Um,
and yeah,
we're really excited about it.
Uh,
so our patrons will still get a better
deal of course.
Uh,
so from where in front of that checkout,
my comment on this video,
also,
one last note,
I've been seeing a number of people
getting offended by my criticism of high
profile liberal audiences mostly,
uh,
although I do not explicitly mentioned
that I'm as much criticizing dose people
as I am the neoconservatives who saw it
as praising the Iraq war.
I'm just trying to provide a,
a new way of looking at the film.
You don't have to agree with me.
Um,
I was just trying to show a structural
message of the film in an objective
manner,
uh,
or at least as objective as possible.
Anyways,
enjoy guys.
Alright.
Hello everyone.
So three days ago,
uh,
I uploaded my American sniper video and
in the meantime we've got a lot of
comments,
questions and criticisms and now I
wanted to make this video to answer and
talk about some of the top comments that
we got and that touch on some important
and the most talked about points.
Uh,
but before I get into any of that,
I want to promote the thesis that I use
for this analysis.
And now just just that I use is called
terministic screens and partisan
audiences,
a birkin cluster analysis of Clint
Eastwood's American sniper by Daniel K
dot Mervin.
Now he uses the same cluster analysis
method of the sickening to film,
but takes it a step further by combining
it with liberal and conservative
terministic screens or in other words,
the weight at both of those groups look
at the world and which terms they
resonate with.
Um,
and he uses both of these things to
examine how either of the parties
interpreted the film food our own
political screen or misinterpreted,
if you will.
You can pause it here if you want to
read it a little bit.
But yeah,
it's,
it's a fairly thought provoking fingers,
a lot of truth in it.
Uh,
it's available for free online.
I'll try to add a link in the
description in the description so you
can check it out if you're interested.
Uh,
yeah.
So yeah,
I mainly use a cluster analysis method
combined with some of his own findings
for my own video,
um,
as it's a great tool to discern the main
themes of a film,
texts objectively,
and to see how to subordinate terms
change value throughout.
All right,
so without further ado,
let's go onto some of the comments.
And the first one is by Ellis.
Oh,
oh,
interesting.
Take on.
The film didn't realize it got so much
hate.
You enter into a difficult area though
when labeling American sniper as anti
war,
which I don't think is necessarily
defined by showing the destructiveness
of war,
but rather by to what extent the
destruction can be justified in the end
as we're American sniper.
The fact that he did get his bad guy at
the end and got a big funeral parade and
hero status.
Granted,
not by everyone but still to me shows
that this is far from an antiwar film.
I'm pretty sure there are plenty of
folks out there who look at a film like
this and think it was all worth it.
Okay.
So I believe this touches on what now
you see it has said in this video about
war films,
if you don't know him,
he's a,
another video ses who,
uh,
is actually fairly,
fairly popular and makes a lot of great
video.
So,
uh,
I'll put a link to that video in the
description as well.
Basically,
his statement is that a film can be
defined as a pro war film if the
benefits outweigh the costs of the war,
which he states is a thing that American
sniper shows.
So although I agree with the observation
of what a pro war film is,
I don't believe it fully applies to
American sniper.
So as I've shown in my video,
the three pillars of Kyle's thinking or
shown to be completely destructive to
family and in some ways even as military
family as it gets to have his friends
skilled.
So never do we see any progress in the
Iraq war as well.
Instead,
things seem to be escalating and getting
worse every time.
Call Kyle comes back.
Um,
and then in the last battle,
we see that even after he wants to
protect his family,
he's still putting himself and other
soldiers in danger.
Now,
I am going to agree with the fact that
there should've been more of a negative
consequence for him,
especially in that last scene which
could have been shown in one of the
other soldiers getting killed or maimed,
but I'll get back to that in a little
bit.
Overall,
I believe that if American sniper war to
be a heavily pro war film showing the
benefits outweighing the costs,
the values that cow carries with him,
which are those highly conservative or
more like neoconservative values,
would definitely not have been depicted
to be so detrimental to family in every
shape and form.
Instead,
those values would have been shown to be
positive and effective in in school and
not entirely flawed.
Also,
I don't believe that the film was pro
war just for portraying someone who
personally was a belief that there isn't
really any benefit over costs in the
film.
We just see to work costing more and
more with less and less benefit.
If we see benefit at all,
in the end,
he dies that the war is and resolve.
The families are still being destroyed
and tries to depict as dogmatic beliefs
the destructiveness of said beliefs and
shows them to be more of a tragic,
a flawed character.
In my opinion.
It is,
however,
still respectful to his intentions as a
person,
which brings us to to portrayal of Chris
Kyle and also our second common by
before the credits.
I would agree with you.
It wasn't for a few things.
I see you mentioned this isn't about
kyle himself,
but he who he was as a real person plays
a part in what the movie became.
It seems he just wasn't a good person at
all.
He lied a lot and it seems to love more
himself,
which isn't shown in a movie that played
a role with the people who watching the
movie dead look more into them.
All right,
so this touches on a part of the films
criticism that I believe hold some
truth.
Clint Eastwood is very obviously careful
to not portray cow as a person in a
negative light,
and as Bradley Cooper has stated,
the film actively tries to put emphasis
on veterans and honors their plight in
the process.
Now,
I think the certain Lakin nuanced depth
and Kyle's character makes that some of
the antiwar elements might've become
overshadowed and angry if that,
um,
I've only read a little bit about the
controversy surrounding him,
so I don't know how much of it is true
or whether this was known to,
to filmmakers are in production.
But what I do know to be true is that
Carl has stated in his autobiography to
have enjoyed,
to have enjoyed killing people in Iraq,
which is,
um,
uh,
something that,
before the credits touched on in his
comment.
Um,
this is something that's only subtly
hinted at the movie.
I think,
uh,
as you know,
you can see tyack questioning Kyle's
real intentions,
uh,
as he wants to go back for a fourth time
because she doesn't believe that he's
doing it to protect his family's
anymore.
But for other,
more personal reasons,
uh,
but I think the film mainly explains
isn't as obsession with killing the
people responsible for murdering his
friends.
Um,
so I would agree that the antiwar
message would have been clear if this
would have been implemented,
uh,
his,
his enjoyment of killing and would have
benefited the quality and the honesty of
the film in general if,
if,
if this aspect of college would have
been shown in the movie.
But I do understand that,
you know,
this would have probably never happened,
even if Clint Eastwood would have wanted
to implement it,
the guy had just been shot.
So I think they were extra careful in
this portrayal.
And besides that,
there's also the possibility that the
studio just wanted to play it safer for
a big audience and that might have
opened the door for a more pro
neoconservative viewing of the film.
Um,
I mean,
this is not Francis Ford Coppola
prancing around half naked in the
Philippine jungles and his own budget.
So I doubt East we'd had complete
liberty in this unless someone can prove
me wrong,
of course.
But that brings us to a number of
questions.
Does Clint Eastwood and directors of war
films in general hold a responsibility
in the interpretation of their films?
So even if you personally wanted to make
it predominantly anti war film,
I'm having part of the audience
interpreted as a pro war film,
does that mean that it is his failure or
failure on his part or is it a failure
on the audience's part to misinterpret
the film?
Does that mean that we have to do away
with subtlety when it comes to sensitive
topics,
does that mean that we have to limit a
director's liberty and in,
in showing his own view,
uh,
or to be political correct.
Politically correct in depicting of
these sensitive topics?
Or is it to be found in the apparent,
this honest portrayal of Chris Kyle,
even though it was only meant to be
roughly based on his life,
are in bio pics in essence problematic
when it comes to creating a fake
narrative around a real person?
Or is it all just fiction and people
shouldn't learn history from fiction
films.
Alright.
So those are some of the questions that
popped up for me and that could further
the conversation in the comments section
because I want to know what you think
about this personally and,
and what your views are a,
I think with that,
I've set most of what I intended to say
and I hope I provided you have some
further context in ways to further the
conversation.
Um,
of course I appreciate constructively,
constructively post varying viewpoints
of which I'm looking forward to seeing
more in this common section.
Uh,
thank you all for watching.